the Senate bill to replace Obamacare
needs some more votes so Republican
leaders are changing it this morning
sources tell CBS News the bill now
includes 45 billion dollars to paper
treating opioid abuse the bill all will
also let people pay health insurance
premiums with the money they've set
aside in their health savings accounts
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
where the president predictably he has
what he calls a big surprise on health
care Margaret good morning good morning
well those tweaks are meant to persuade
reluctant Senate Republicans to help
overhaul this health care law that
President Trump vowed to fix but it
isn't clear if they can get there and
the president said he's going to give
them a little bit more time to make it
perfect traveling just a few blocks from
the White House for a fundraiser at the
Trump branded hotel the president
couldn't elude protesters unhappy with
his support of the Senate health care
plan he did however elude reporters who
were not allowed to cover mr. Trump's
remarks just five months into his
presidency the event was billed as a
reelection fundraiser three hundred
donors paid $35,000 per plate leading to
a one night haul of about ten million
dollars but when it comes to his own
agenda success remains elusive we could
have a big surprise with a great health
care package the president offered no
explanation as to what that might be but
with nine Republican senators opposing
the bill a sudden breakthrough this week
would be unexpected adding to the
urgency of the debate two more insurers
in Nevada announced they're pulling out
of the Obamacare exchange blaming
uncertainty in Washington the move will
leave more than 8,000 people without
coverage Nevada's governor declared the
situation of crisis with protests likely
to continue Republicans face the choice
of coming together to fix the
deteriorating health care law or the
unlikely option of finding a compromise
with Democrats let's turn over a new
leaf
but Minority Leader Chuck Schumer urged
President Trump to restart negotiations
a process the Democrats claimed they
were excluded from President Trump I
challenge you to invite
all hundred of us to discuss a new
bipartisan way forward on health care in
front of all the American people mr.
Trump was skeptical he just doesn't seem
like a serious person Majority Leader
McConnell plans to have the bill revised
by tomorrow so he can get the
Congressional Budget Office to score
just how much it'll cost and who it'll
cover while Congress goes on recess for
the holiday Nora all right lots ahead
Margaret thank you